Merhaba ben hikayeme 1996 yılında Bingöl
olay bölgesinden başlayacağım
Bu benim Bingöl'de karakolda gördüğüm
ilk sahne
yani tahmin edeceğiniz üzere insanlar ne
kadar sıkılmış terhis olduklarına da
lambada yapıyorlar
ve Kendi kendime düşündüm dedim ki ya
Güngör'e geldim o argo girmesin diye
996'dan bahsediyorum hardceler
ve de şöyle bir özelliği var hayatında
hiç kendime Sıkılmak için fırsat
tanımadım peki burada ne yapabilirdim
Kaçak 2 tane ama bak fotoğraf makinesi
soktu yasaktı ve fotoğraf çekmeye
başladım işte operasyona gidiyoruz daha
fotoğraf çektirdik işte karakolda
kalıyor ben fotoğraf çekiyorum herkes
İzine gidiyor ben herkesin kullandığı
fotoğraf çekiyor
ve
yaklaşık birden fazla fotoğraf çektim
silahların hepsi boş emniyetlere de
kafam merak ettim
ve sonra şunu sorgulamaya başladı
burada yaşayan insanlar
ve diğer tüm
aldatı da yaşayan
insanlar aradaki farklılıklar ve guarda
21 o konuyu yurtdışında okumuşum
gelmişim Bir sene sonra Bingöl'de her
şeyi bütün Bildiğim her şeyini unuttum
ne yapabilirim diye kafa patlatmaya
başladım Neyse Askerlik bitti Tekrar
sivil hayata geri dönelim
geri döndükten sonra
sahibi komutuna kafaya taktım Çünkü
saygı toplumunun temelini oluşturan en
büyük oğlu belgeyi sevdik bir yere kadar
sayfalık bir şey fakat sahibi devamında
toplumsal huzuru getiriyor mesela Uzun
şeylerden bir tanesi
farklı olduğumuz için bir günümüze
benzeriz
sana benzediğini
aşağılama işte Ama Çünkü her birimiz
birimiz kadar Farklıyız
farka sahibinin Yaklaşık 40 metrelik bir
eksiden Bir heykel yaptım 1 yıl sürdü
nereye yerleştireceğim bilmiyorum
sonunda bir yer buldum
bir Transporter küçük küpler ve
Büyüklükler esas olayı küçüklükler ve
Büyüklükler insan egosunu temsil
ediyordu ve hepsini dengesiz biçimde
birbirlerine birleştirip burada Toprak
dünyayı temsil ediyor
Taksim metrosuna koydum
Bayağı da bir kaydı ve yaklaşık 12 tane
sanatçı dosyasını rica ettim
yaptığım bir şey onlarda katkıda
bulundum hepsi bir arayışını
yerleştirdiler 10 günde 110 bin kişi
ziyaret etti
Bu arada sergiye katılan arkadaşlarına
iki tanesi evlendi
tabi 10 gün boyunca orada 110 bin kişi
galiba Ben saat 12'de kadar her gelenle
bir şekilde etkileşimde bulundum
fikirler falan anlattım Daha sonra
Ya ben aslında ülkede kimseyi
tanımıyormuşum gölge bölge kim ne
yaşıyorum ben onu görüyorum
Sivaslılar diye sabah bir hafta sonra
sabah kalktım atlayıp Bütün Türkiye'ye
dolaştım
neredeyse ve bir toplumsal araştırma
belgeseli çektim
günde 1+1 eşittir 3 ve tek bir soru
sordum bugüne kadar yaşadıklarınızdan
çıkarttınız hayat dersi nedir
aldığım cevaplar beni başka bir yöne
etkiliyor hep sizinlemek tek tek arka
arkaya gidiyor
mutsuz top
bizim toplumumuz bir sus
Çünkü saygı yok
farklı menfaatlerin elinde olan bir
eğitim sistemi Bence eğitim sistemi tüm
dünyada Tamamen benim Kafamdaki sistemle
ilgili hepsi çöp
sanat ve sınırları mesela sanatçı kim
sanat Ne sağa toplumda değer
mesleklerden ayıran özellik ne sorular
sormaya başladı
ve benim için sanat Duygu reflekslerini
harekete geçiren bir şey yani
güzel bir yemek yediğinizde Bunu size
hazırlayan da aslında
bir tatlı alsa bir şey hissetsek Dünür
reflekse Bu da benim için sabah benim
için herkes sanat
Yeter ki bunu kullanarak gülmek önemli
daha
sonra
ne yapabilirim diye düşünmeye başladım
Evet ben bir şey üretiyorum ve Duygu
reflekslerini harekete geçirmek
istiyorum o zaman resim yapıyor bu resim
yaptığım resimleri
bedava vereyim
hediye edeyim nasıl yapabilirim bir
arkadaşım var Adam Kaya diye kendisi
direktman şeyden manyak mısın gel
konuşalım Hani böyle şeyleri ne
yapıyorsun falan filan
konuştuk ben kafamdakileri
Ama temmuz diye bir arkadaşımla işim
arka tarafındaki Metin yazılarını
hazırladım
ve dünyadaki bütün çöplükleri kendime
sergi almayı ilan etti
bunu da sekizinci İstanbul fuarıda gibi
başladım Bir buçuk sene önce
geçen sene yapılan Çağrı hesabı var
burada da
kaçıp 3 tane sokup çöpe
koyduk çok kolay
ve üzerinde bedava
çok var ya elimizde tabloyduk girersiniz
bilet bile almanıza gerek yok işte bir
şey zannediyor dua kokuları açılıyor
biliyorsunuz
falan öyle kaldı sonra verdik
ve bu sefer şey dedi yani
saygıyı sorguluyor Kim kime ne kadar
saygı duyuyor
neden saygı duymak zorundayız sahibi
olmazsa neler oluyor
incelik kısmında projenin Kafalar hep
karışık
eleştirmenler eleştirmenleri çok
seviyorum nedense çünkü attığım için
eserlerimi hiçbir şekilde
eleştiremiyorlar kötü resmi değil mi
çöpe atıyorum
çok güzel olmuş Evet ama çok
sonra sana verileri ve koleksiyonerler
girdi devreye ve cübbe attığım resimleri
ilk başta 3000 TL işler alanlara teklif
ediyorlar telefon açıyorlar vesaire
bin sene kimse satmadı
toplamda 417 tane çöp attık bugüne kadar
resmi bırakacak
ve onlara bir yazı yolladım Hani gelin
size
değersiz oldukları kadar da
parayı paha biçilmez oluyor şu anda
hiçbir değeri yok Bir bu attığım ilk çöp
Taksim İlk Yardım Hastanesi'nin arkası
Tabii bekliyoruz Temmuz kamerayı çekiyor
Ben bir tarafta bekliyordum çünkü koyduk
kimse almıyor herkes çatlıyor veya
geçmiyor yani bir saat geçti bir buçuk
saat geçti dedi
çift yolda işte erkek hiç önemli değil
ziyaret etmişsin
onlara
başladım macera
daha sonra bunun sosyal medya üzerinden
duymaya başladım Kafalar hep karışık
diye bir eşek açtım
ve orada nereye saat kaçta çöpe
atacağımı söylemeye başladım ki hani
bekliyorsunuz Çünkü almıyorlar ne
vakalar benim
Kiler sonuç çoğalmaya başladı
Bu da 3 tane atmam ama iki kişi geldi
Bir de bende kaldı ağızda zaten
daha sonra işte diyenler çoğalmaya
başladı
gitgide çoğalmaya başladı
daha da çoğalmaya başladı Şimdi burası
Bursa galiba Bursa'da
Evet esas hedefim olan saygı kısmında
Ümraniye'de Çınar gibi yani kültür
derneğinden hitabet aldım evet Gene
çocuklar herkes çocuklardan bahsediyor
Bence de çocuklar her zaman
benim en saygı duyduğum var dedi Ve
onlarla beraber gönüllü olarak resim
yapmaya başladım
ve beraber çok pahalı
hepsi Mutlu ve çok güzeldi
bir süre sonra gelenler çoğalmaya
başlayınca Aslında biraz da koyacağım
satmaya başladı çünkü şeyi hissettim
Mesela 10 kişi geliyor bir tane resmi
var işte ben geldim o geldi de teyzemin
oğlu aradı işte doğum günü falan hiç
verdi O zaman dedim ben haber vermemeye
başlayayım bu sefer haber vermeden
bırakmaya başladım
İstanbul Teknik Üniversitesi'nin tasarım
bölümünde yeni davet edildim projemi
anlattım ve tekrar Türkiye Eğitim
gemileri vaktinde çocuklarla tekrar
çalışmaya devam etti onlarla beraber çok
farklı
yani sabah çocuklarla beraber resim
yapıyor ama akşam üniversiteliler
geliyor yine çok devam
ediyor hikaye biraz daha
enteresanlaşacak tabi sonra bu
Türkiye'deki sanatçıların dikkatini
çekti onlar vermek istedi çok bal
onda Bu sefer daha çok
insan ama ben bir tanesini atıyorum
devamlı aralarında bir tartışma
tekrar haber vermemeye başladım fark
ettiyseniz çoğalıyor sonra tek
kişi yine çocuklarla çalışmaya devam
ettim
bir çalışma temposunun içinde Bu arada
şöyle bir kendi belgeselini de çekmeye
başladım projeyi başladığından itibaren
2 senedir hiç para kazanmadım
hiç param yok
dostlarım sayesinde onlar ortaklaşa işte
biri bir akşam yemek yapıyor oraya
gidiyor bir tarafa gelebileceksen bir
Yürüyerek gidiyor iki araç kullanan
devam ediyoruz
daha sonra sokak çocukları ile daha
doğrusu sokak çocuğu da yanlış bitirmiş
sokakta yaşayan çocuklarla beraber
çalışmaya devam ettim
onların Maltepe Üniversitesi'ndeki
derneğinde beraber çalışmalar yapmaya
başladık ki beni eleştirenler için en
güzel cevabı bende şu yüzler veriyor
Hatta bence bu işlemez bir şekilde bu
derin ikinci
kısmı daha sonra tabii Bu Yay
ıldı mesela sosyal medya üzerinden ve
Danimarka'dan bir davet aldım
Danimarkalı en büyük
sokak sanatı festivalinde 7 ayrı şehirde
20 gün boyunca resimlerini Çöpe atmamı
istediler neden martıya gittim
kültürümüzden bir parça
ve sonra Amigo
Berlin'den bir davet aldım ve Amigo ile
beraber ortak çalışmalara başladık
Burası dairenin en arkadan sor ben de
geç
iyorum ve Almanya'nın en önemli Sokak
sanatçılarından biri olan Mehmet ile
beraber ortak çalışmaya başladık Onunla
beraber çalışma fırsatı buldum ki bu
benim için çok önemli bir durumdu
işimize ortaklaşa beraber bir şeyler
yapmaya başladı
burası Antep modern sanatlar Müzesi'nin
kapısı
yani çöpe atacaktık kimseyi engellemedi
daha gittik daha gittik Bir kapıdan
içeri gir
dik daha Güvenmek yok daha da içerikli
en son son kapının orada bütün baktım
daha sonra rotardam'a geçtim rotterdamla
bir parka enstitasyonlarını bırakmaya
başladım Burada işte boyadım mantarla
ve tekrar rahat verdi geri dönüp
Avrupa'da yaptığım en büyük resmi yapıp
Orada herkesin görebileceği ziyaret
edebileceği bir yere asıldı zaten tek
şartım yani
büyük resimlerde daha çok versiyonu var
orada devam etti
ve Geri döndüğümde herhalde çok yalnız
hissettim kendim duvarlara sarılmaya
başladım yani boyayacağım bu yani duvar
boyu neden duvar
boyanıyor nasıl olduğunu bir de İstanbul
duvar boyamak için gerçekten çok uygun
ki duvarlar bomboş tek Kara
payabiliyorsunuz O da moda olduğu için
herkes oynuyor
sonra benim Kafalar hep karışık
duvarlara boyamaya başladım
Burası da yani
daha sonra tekrar bir açıklama
antrepta bir Çinli lisansörle beraber
full gibi bakıyor Belki çok fazla konuş
ma çok görsel olduğu için böyle patlat
tım ve bu yaptıklarımın hepsini parasız
yaptım eminim arkadaşımla bahsettiği
gibi eğer bir şey hayal kuruyorsanız
Gerçekten bu gerçekleşiyor ama
patlatmanın zaman harcamanız
Beraber yaptığımız bir çalışmalıyız
tekrar ben davetiydim Berlin'de tekrar
girmek gün hani böyle beraber dünyada
polis tarafından öldürülen gençlerin
portresini çizip tedavisini olarak çöpe
bıraktık mahallesinden
yani karşılaştığımız şeyler de çok
enteresan mesela burada bir resmi
verip para yok diyoruz para
çıkartıyorlar Yok yok para yok diyoruz o
zaman Elma veriliyorlar elma elinde
yemenizi bekliyorlardı
yani hayallerimizin Peşinden gidelim
küçük
küçüklerden bir tanesi oldu
Sabahtan beri konuştu falan
tekrar verdim
sonra daha
yok
taşım Toprağı Altın İstanbul herkes göç
ediyor İstanbul da her yer altın görüş
durumu var bende O zaman ben de
İstanbul'a altına koymaya başlıyorum
Elektrikler de var Elektrik kabloları
duba çatlak duvar
çöp kovası ve Belediye binası bugün
boyuyorum onlara bir gün gri boyuyorum
bir gün ters çeviriyorum onlar da ters
çevirip oyunu falan bu çok en
teresan arkadaşlar
ımız oturacağım falan da görev verdiler
uyuyor
kapışıyoruz kimin parası bitmez
Arnavut kaldırımlarını altına koymaya
başladım
daha sonra Logar kapaklarını Bu da çok
enteresan bütün manevi yaşlı teyzeleri
şu anda buraya gelip kapıya bizim
mahalledeki Logar kapaklarını da böyle
çok güzel
bir bölümü aldım şu an
su giderleri
öpmeye çalıştılar şu sağ tarafı falan
daha sonra en son bir park boyadım
altına Bunların hepsi bu arada ila
beraber boyarken de online olarak
sarılmaktan sıkıp zorlamak direkleri
öpmeye başladım
dantel konusu hani çok bize ait olan
eski şeyleri hatırlatmak adına dantel
desenli stenciler yapmaya başladım
Don Kişot
daha sonra sulu boyalarımı trafikte
lambalarını bırakıp yine bir dersiniz
altına görebilirsiniz yaklaşık haftada
20 25 tane bırakıyorum
farklı
her yer sergi alalım çok rahat
daha sonra çok fazla sıkmayın birikti
bunları nasıl geri dönecek Benim için de
değerlendirebilirim diye düşünüp onlar
da hani tercihler yapmaya başladım
Bunlar da bedelsiz
olarak bu olaylar başaklarından buldum
bir motorun Hani bu altın konseptini
biraz daha Hani dikkat çekmesi için bu
sefer başka bir objeler boyamaya
başladım mesela
bu altın olduğu gibi daha sonra
göstermesi lazım
bu portakalı bunu da servisi Yarın
Haydarpaşa garındayız Dilerseniz
hepinize davet
ediyoruz ve sonuç olarak anlatmak
istediğim şey fotoğraf linkler video ve
sokak sokak sanatıyla giden bir
düzlemde devam ediyor pratik yaptığım
şey ne istiyorsam onu yapıyorum
Hiçbir şey umurumda değilim Bana Manyak
mısın oğlum parasız mı yaşadığı şey mi
yapılır diyen herkes geçen sene oturdu
Ben 7 tane Avrupa ülkesi dolaştım
yani
Bir de herkes böyle bir sonda bir şey
söyledi bir tek şerit olmuyor bireysel
devrimini yapın kendinize de yapın Ne
istiyorsanız onu yapın Kimsenin
umursamayın ne istiyorsanız onu seçin
teşekkürler